die gch sich beschissen wenn ich dich so
sehen also jetzt mir auch sicher sein
was sagst du dazu ich würde ich gerne
umbringen
ja so war es ist viel zu früh
allerdings ist es gerade so früh weil
ich jetzt zum bahnhof köln fahrer und
dann vom bahnhof mit dem zukauf nach
bösen wundervoll aussicht es ist so viel
vergangenheit deutschland ich bin auf
jeden fall in österreich angekommen ist
alle der erhält es ist mittlerweile
tatsächlich schon dunkel draußen und er
hat auch schon
es regnet ja dann fahre ich einfach kein
ski auf jeden fall sind meine schwester
und ich jetzt schon im hotel angekommen
überall liegen schon sachen von uns rum
ich packe meinen koffer aus und morgen
schon eine epische musik machen worden
eine alpaka haben wir fahren auf jeden
fall morgen schon um 38.000 den vorort
von unseren weg von unserer ordentlichen
verordnung da wo wir sind dann eben
vielleicht 15 leute oder sowie viele
wohnen in dem ort eine person der
wahrscheinlich halt nur der typ mit
alpakas jeden fall will ich jetzt auch
gar nicht mehr lange lagern ich bin auf
jeden fall übertrieben ist müde und ich
würde sagen wir sehen uns morgen
wir sehen uns doch nicht beim frühstück
wieder denn die alpaka tour wurde
abgesagt
aufgrund von schlechtem wetter es ist am
stein ist schön kalt wie soll sonst
seien in österreich auf jeden fall wurde
die einfache herzlich willkommen zum
besten job der welt die avantgarde und
jetzt auf jeden fall abgesagt
beziehungsweise nicht komplett abgesagt
sondern verschoben auf übermorgen
da soll kompletter schneesturm sein also
das wird auf jeden fall megafon klappen
dann allerdings habe ich jetzt aber man
hingefallen
ich habe frei genommen für diese alpaka
wanderung und jetzt schaue ich mir den
ganzen tag im schnee und mehr freunde
ich gehe jetzt erstmal einen spa-bereich
ein bisschen chillen update ich wie ihr
sehen könnt wird doch nicht im spa
bereich sondern gehe jetzt mit mama in
dem kleinen ort dort dürfen hier wird er
war
brief weg bringen vielleicht hätte ich
doch bessere schulen sollen
[Musik]
wir wollten ja eigentlich ein alpaka
wanderung machen
die findet jetzt morgen statt morgen um
10 uhr findet die stadt die sollte
eigentlich gestern stattfinden aber da
kommen immer mehr da hinten ist gerade
noch ein anderes alpaka herausgekommen
ist irgendwie süß aber irgendwie total
hessen also genauso wie ich wir sind
jetzt mal von hinten an den start
gegangen und irgendwie haben die keinen
bock auf uns der folgende hahn hängen
was haben die denn da alles in dem
verhängen
sieht schon süß
eigentlich wollte mein brief weg bringen
jetzt zweimal hatte gefühlt eine halbe
stunde bei den alpakas und das war die
post schon dann verkackt
[Musik]
hammer videofilms deshalb österreich 190
einfach verlangt man hier sind so 1000
kühe plötzlich dieses haus beschreibt
seit österreich in einem bild hier ist
dieses haus und diese halten
fensterläden jetzt eine krippe und
dahinter sind tiere die es auch ein tier
ist auf jeden fall wieder zurück ins
hotel und dann werde ich bis hin zu
beraten
ich habe gerade viel strom bekannt
welcher tag ist hier habe ich dort
einfach geschlafen für vier stunden und
das ist einfach arschkalt und meine
hände
deswegen heißt wir keine ahnung dass die
letzte szene in diesem blog war weil ich
absolut keinen plan hat was sich in
diesem blog bisher schon gefilmt habe
und ihr kennt mich wenn ich blogge ich
habe übrigens ziemlich die augenringe
weil ich ziemlich wenig gepennt habe
aber das interessiert ja das nicht was
ich aber den interessiert ist das hier
glaube ich
es hat uns schön geschneit und die jetzt
ist die alpaka wanderung die alpaka
wanderungen wurde abgesagt der paarung
findet jetzt in drei tagen statt am 26
und das hier ist ein roller neuer alpaca
wanderungen soll ist auf jeden fall am
26 dezember stattfinden weil ich der 23
drei tagen aber auch darauf stattfinden
wird oder auch ausfallen wird
allerdings mache jetzt wieder spa rasen
bringen
es sieht einfach aus die pässe und
schmeckt auch so wenn man die nachkochen
will braucht man sellerie möhren kohl
blumenkohl täter sitzen und ich bin auch
noch mit drin
bis in die seele baumeln lassen
ich habe jetzt eine entspannende
gesichtsbehandlung der leute ich hab
gerade sonne in street frucht service
behandlung gemacht als er mir ging es
noch nie so beschissen wenn der haut
fühlt sich an als wären all das hand
drüber gelaufen ich absolut keine ahnung
ist die letzte szene in diesem blog war
erst lokaler zeit mal wieder zurück aber
auf jeden fall gehen jetzt in die kirche
weise zeitlich abend in der kirche war
es mir ja schön aber seht ihr das hier
und hier dann zur seite
ich hatte angst meine damen und herren
ich habe mal wieder surprise surprise
vergessen was die letzte szene war vor
weihnachten ich verstehe wirklich nicht
warum wir so viele leute beschreiben das
nicht mehr blocken
was ich aber eigentlich sagen wollte ist
dass es total windig ist hier gerade in
österreich und wir haben das fenster zu
in unserem hotelzimmer und die tür dort
ist auch zu aber ich hatte euch mal kurz
neben die tür damit ihr mal hört was
hier von der geräuschkulisse stattfindet
hätte das und dann macht man die tür auf
als weg tür wieder zu dazu ja ich glaube
ich doch mal schlafen gehen
kurzes update für alpaka wanderungen die
sollte eigentlich schon längst
stattgefunden haben deswegen dachte ich
auch dass ich eigentlich nur filme wie
hier nach österreich fahren dann kommt
die eine bergwanderung und dass der
workshop phase vorbei stattdessen ist es
jetzt eine gequirlte scheiße mich jeden
tag irgendwie etwas anderes was ich
mache und es hat gar keinen roten faden
also freunde das update zur alpaca
wanderungen heute ist der 25 das heißt
morgen ist der 26 die alpaka wanderung
findet morgen mittag startet morgen um
14 uhr dann heißt für euch ist es ja eh
gleich dass ihr die alpakas sind aber
für mich ist es quasi in 24 stunden
es hat dieser kompletter block überhaupt
kennt mich jetzt in ruhe und dann sehen
uns morgen bei der einwanderung wieder
wir sind angekommen bei gewissen tieren
die ihr da hinten schon was gleich
hacker bekommen die letztes jahr da habe
ich ein foto auf ins hochland und jetzt
habe ich wieder enrico enrico hallo ich
bin enrico der aller coolste der
anführer der truppe wird männlich und
das sind alles weiler und dass er hinten
sind auch in zwei von diesen gaildorf
enrico frauenheld enrico ja nur wenige
minuten später in recording wenig zurück
zu laufen ein kurzes update enrico hat
mich bisher dreimal angespuckt weil ich
so recht du arschloch
ich wollte ihm einen stock aus dem feld
ziehen edition spuckt mich amt enrico
und die wunderschöne flusslandschaft
fronten rico ist die wanderung
tatsächlich überraschen langweilig
relativ normal nicht ja wie bereits
dreimal angespuckt zu beginnen aber
sonst wenn ich dich sehe also jetzt mir
auch die anderen alpakas haben bisher
noch kein mal gespuckt denn rico schon
dreimal straight in mein gesicht das
statement dass du mit dir rede ich nicht
mediaplayer zum motto sprach leute mein
leben könnte so schön sein dass ich auf
einer wiese stehe und eine coole zeit
habe mit meinen alpaka freundin aber
stattdessen muss ich mit so einem lauf
durch österreich laufen gibt diesem
video einen daumen louis also solch
super zwischen uns wir machen gerade
eine kleine tour finden später haben uns
beruhigte frister blätter grad
irgendwie so ich kann essen was ich will
die penner gesichts und die kleine
hessen trinkpause ist beendet er hat
mich gerade das fünfte mal angespuckt er
noch gar keinen bock auf mich ich gehe
sofort die ganze zeit zur seite sagte er
sei wieder wird sehen wir immer noch
euer alpaka tour schlechthin mit enrico
wann ist diese scheiß endlich vorbei ist
das immer noch recht in rico und eine
gondelbahn seilbahn enrico was sagst du
dazu ich würde dich gerne umbringen
ja super mein kleines update für euch
unsere tour setzt gleichen
vorbeigelaufen gerade wieder zurück in
richtung bauernhof und enrico endlich
getrennt von bienen so geht es mir auch
recht spaßig aber wieder abgegeben hier
draußen stehen jetzt nur noch die weiber
die machen halt im auge auf ein rekord
so schön mit euch ja das glaube ich alle
nichts für mich
da ist er wieder der beschissenen
blogger auf ganz europa auf ganz europa
meine damen und herren es ist
mittlerweile ich habe keine uhr an
gerade noch abendessen und waren danach
im hotel
allerdings gehe ich jetzt auch wenn
meine lieben freundinnen heute bei der
letzte tag hier bei uns im hotel in
österreich und morgen reisen hier ab das
heißt ich würde sagen ich nerve ich gar
nicht mehr weiter wir sehen uns jetzt in
köln wieder wenn ich zu hause bin
in fred raten april union schwer
erkennen können dann hat der ganzen
smileys hier in dem kompletten zimmer
ich bin zurück in köln angekommen und
wird jetzt allerdings auch gar nicht
mehr lange lagern sondern die glocken
der stellt das er ja am ende ich habe
jetzt ist neun tage am stück geblockt
und ich glaube der blog hatte überhaupt
keinen roten faden er hatte gar keinen
richtigen inhalt ich habe einfach nur
immer wenn ich bock hatte die kammer da
rausgeholt und irgendwann erzählt
gefallen hat das gerne einen daumen hoch
oder der video da soll ich da irgendwie
alpaca wanderung machen oder so schreibt
sie gerne in die kommentare frontmann
auf instagram ich heiße dort laser luca
habe dort auch ein foto mit den einpark
hochgeladen oder neun fotos habe ich mit
den absacker vogler
also schaut ihr euch daran dass leichter
bei dem bild da abonniert main kanal
falls doch kein teil der luft und das
video ist jetzt auch vorbei
[Musik]